happy New Year folks and welcome to
rational science
uh hope it's gonna be a great year I was
raining here I felt had problems sorry
to hear that uh for 2022 hopefully 2023
is better for everyone but in this site
we say that man will become extinct
quite soon actually uh probably would
within most of our lifetime people were
alive today
and um so but I'm going to start this
year new year 2023 is The Countdown to
Extinction
and I'm going to be mentioning the main
points uh not all I listed a couple here
uh brainstormed a couple uh but they
don't cover the whole uh range of uh
reasons I believe uh man's gonna become
extinct quite soon
um and it's got to do primarily with the
theory theory is really not a question
of belief you can believe it or not but
uh the re the the
um the um the theory should be objective
okay the explanation of the mechanism
and so these are the issues okay that I
usually raise
I hope I'm still on I got a message from
uh
whoa
I hope everybody can see and hear me uh
I'm getting an error from YouTube
let me know otherwise
let me know if you can hear me
can everybody hear me or see me
I got a message from YouTube saying that
they're not receiving uh
any uh
signal
all good
okay thank you
okay anyways
um like I was saying
um I'm gonna start a Countdown to
Extinction these are the main reasons
that I think humans will become extinct
relatively soon whatever soon means to
you I think within our generation
whatever you think of uh uh whatever
meaning the word generation you know
whatever that means to you right
everybody's got a different notion of
what a generation is but these are the
um these are the things that I have
going through my mind
um saying that the population pyramid of
the of humans has overturned
um that's because in great measure we
moved to the cities from the country
over the last 200 years and so we have
what is known as density dependent birth
rates uh there's this urbanization
process going on okay uh we because of
that because of inbreeding we have this
loss of genetic diversity okay and we're
having genetic disorders gives me an
idea that we're more or less at the end
of the line of our species
um the ecological pyramid uh is going to
overturn at the end okay that means that
we're going to have the many chasing
after the few specifically we're going
to run out of food we're going to run
out of food because no one's going to
produce it once the economy falls apart
global economy uh the motor production
is going in the direction of services
and we can't stop that services are
abstractions that we really don't need
except to run what we do need which is
manufacturing or more specifically
agriculture
uh we also have a service Revolution
with within Services we're moving into
the internet World we're doing more and
more work in Internet which is even more
abstract and less and less Services
where we use our hands you know such as
barbering and Landscaping stuff like
that
um
uh we have a devaluation inflation in
the economy uh we have unemployment or
masked employment you go to several
countries out there and you'll find that
people sell whatever they can just to
survive one more day including drugs
and uh governments they have Unstoppable
Rising debt all they do is just uh
borrow and then create money to cover
the hole
and always there's this uh thing hanging
over our head known as nuclear war
okay so yeah these are the main reasons
that I have going through my head uh or
at least the most important ones there
could be others and those are the ones
that I usually cover and the ones that I
will be covering this year okay so uh
that's just a notification so that
people are aware of it
okay uh here's uh something that's going
on and that's uh China okay China has
been uh growing in the last maybe 50
years since the days of Mao Zedong and
um Nixon Nate in his days uh he went all
the way to China to the Communists and
Nixon was a fervent anti-communist and
yet he went to the Communists and says
let's do business okay he saw a
potential in China and that helped I
think China more than the United States
but it certainly helped the United
States as well because he could sell a
lot of products to this enormous
population and what it did essentially
is
um fueled the expansion of China okay
and China today now is uh big competitor
of the United States especially in the
uh in industrial World okay and so you
got to think about you know how how that
came about anyways here is uh the
problem today that China is
slowing down okay and uh this is Mr she
okay he's the premier of China and since
China is losing its place at the center
of the world's Supply chains and they're
saying they're going to be diversifying
to other countries that will be maybe
replacing China as manufacturers
countries that pay less to their workers
and it can take some of the
industrialization away from China
okay so uh yeah that's one of the things
you got to keep in mind China may not
grow at the same rate as it has in the
past
and here's a more evidence of that you
can see that
um
China's economy is slowing down
uh but if you put a a curve on that even
before the covid you can see here you
know what happened
um it was already falling apart since uh
at least 1982 according to this in other
words their growth rate uh is not uh
steady it's been falling okay and so uh
yeah and I think it'll continue to fall
no matter what even if they fix the
covet problem that they have right now
I'm not sure China will be able to grow
at the same rate that it grew in the 70s
and 80s okay some point uh you know they
recess growth rate uh maximum and then
from that point on they just start
dropping and they become like any other
developed country okay that's that's my
point okay and here you have uh Chinese
growth
that needs for population growth I'm
sorry and you can see that they
implemented that one child per family
policy and I think even without that the
Chinese uh population would uh continue
to drop and it would continue to drop
simply because people are moving to the
cities they're abandoning the country
they're abandoning agriculture first
moving into manufacturing and from there
into services and you can see uh here
that the breakdown for uh China you know
um in the last from 1978 to 2007 the
percentage of services has ballooned in
China and so if Mr XI thinks that
um something's going to change that
they're going to continue growing
forever well he's got pink elephants uh
you know revolving around his head uh I
don't think he can avoid the same Trend
that happened to all other Advanced
Nations and that is at some point you
know they're they're gonna turn the
corner and they can't grow forever at
the same rate that they've always been
growing it's happened to every country
in China is no exception and uh this is
what the Chinese pie chart looks today
looks like today Services has
um beaten industry it used to be the
other way around now Services has
overtaken industry not to mention
agriculture which as you can see it
becoming a smaller percentage of the
economy not only as a percentage of GDP
but also in terms of Labor because a lot
of this is being uh mechanized they're
using machines to do a lot of the work
uh that used to be done by hand okay so
this is one issue uh you can see if if
you compare this against the United
States which is a country that's been
through that process already in the past
uh the United States has bigger
percentages it's got almost 80 percent
in Services about 15 in manufacturing
okay so uh China is going to go in that
direction and I don't think it can avoid
it and services will become a bigger
percentage as time goes by of the
Chinese economy so all I can say is keep
an eye on that Trend okay and
um but what's the problem with Internet
services
well uh internet uh internet services uh
within Services is growing as well and
here's just one data point okay uh a
little article out there says uh that
Global broadband internet services
Market Grew From 350 70 billion to 400
billion in 22 in 2022 in one year and by
2026 they expect it to go almost 500
billion in other words this this is a
market that's growing uh everybody's
getting on the Internet and I'm not sure
they can avoid that it's uh it's simply
the way uh
um of the market everybody's just moving
in the direction of Internet services
and that means that's going to
eventually take up more and more labor
more people are going to go into that
and it's going to crowd out all other
services let alone manufacturing and
Agriculture and so if we include
um
internet services the pie chart might
look something like this where Services
uh together with internet will be maybe
around 80 percent but a big chunk of
that will be internet services and that
will continue to grow and crowd out all
other services let alone manufacturing
and agriculture so those are the trends
that I see and uh
not everybody sees the same thing but
that's what I'm seeing and I don't think
it I first of all I think it's
unavoidable okay I don't think we can
avoid that Trend and some people say
well it's it's good
um I don't think so because we're we're
getting into more and more abstractions
and uh and stuff that we don't need and
it's crowding up crowding out the things
that we do need
and that means we're all becoming more
and more dependent on someone else
producing for example food and
distributing it to us and what do we do
well we do internet services
and so we pay them and that's why they
do it and if the global economy happens
to crash collapse well maybe they won't
accept money anymore okay and I've
talked about that in the past and no
it's not a maybe they won't at some
point money will clap collapse money
will be no more no one will accept money
any kind of money
even bartering because the only thing
um you can barter when money is no more
is food that's the only thing of value
nothing else has any value whatsoever we
go to the days the days of our
pre-history you know maybe to the uh
upper Paleolithic where we uh used to
kill an animal and live one more day and
that's how we will care about food and
there won't be any food because nobody
will produce it because there won't be
any money so it's going to be a circular
self-feeding mechanism
anyways uh one of those is
says uh Ben should be at work while
women should be at home raising children
[Laughter]
and he goes out and running on uh you
know uh
the proper place for women you know it's
not in the job market it's you know with
an apron in the kitchen
well here's someone who I think out
ranks him in age and probably in money
as well and he says something like this
uh this is the Home Depot 93 year old
co-founder and he says the following he
says uh
um today nobody wants to work nobody is
working he says everybody just wants to
stay at home do what maybe internet
and collect some kind of uh paycheck
from somewhere uh what he calls
socialism which it is you know and uh
and so I don't know um I don't know if
uh if this other fella is correct that
you know um the correct place for women
is in the kitchen uh those were the old
days but
also the old days where that people
worked
and today we don't have uh people
working anymore uh there's less and less
work and I think the old generation like
this gentleman you know they see that
they see there's there's been a change
and unavoidable uh uh change that and
we're not going back to where we were so
not only are we not going back to being
workers like we used to but uh women are
not going to go back to the kitchen okay
so I don't know uh you gotta just come
to terms with that okay
whether it's good or bad well that
depends on everybody's opinion the issue
is uh objective will we go back I say we
won't okay I don't think that's so much
an opinion I think it's a reality
okay uh here another fellow says uh with
billions of people there's plenty of
diversity thanks to mutations okay
because I talked about the fact that
inbreeding leads to a loss of genetic
diversity over time a species can only
lose genetic diversity from its
Inception to when it finally disappears
from the face of the Earth and we're a
species we belong to the Animal Kingdom
for some of those who don't believe that
we are animals in every sense of the
word we are not the Gardeners of Eden
we're just a little another little
animal there okay and uh so yeah we're
losing our genetic diversity we have
almost very little genetic diversity
compared to other mammals we are the
part of the mammal Kingdom by the way
also and this uh thinks that you know
that we produce more genetic diversity
because we have mutations every day and
those mutations serve to enrich
our gene pool
another fella has a different opinion
we'll just contrast what he said to this
fellow and he says the following he says
inbreeding individuals decrease genetic
I guess he took this from somewhere okay
but no problem uh we're just stating
what uh the worldly wisdom is out there
among geneticists or people who study
these things
in Reading individuals decrease genetic
variation by increasing homozygosity in
the genomes of their offspring thus the
likelihood of deleterious recessive
alleles to pair is significantly higher
in small inbreeding populations than in
larger inbreeding populations in other
words if you have um
a small group
uh Founders founders effect you know you
have 10 people and from there you start
something in inbreeding there's going to
be less genetic diversity in that group
than if you have a billion people that's
all they're saying here but it says any
two humans differ on average this is
today okay on average at about one in
one thousand DNA based pairs okay and
human genetic diversity is substantially
lower than that of many other species
including our nearest evolutionary
relative the chimpanzee and yeah here's
uh the uh study uh just one of the uh
examples out there that they did a
couple studies really uh of chimpanzees
in Africa they compared their genetics
against ours and they say look we got a
problem because all these chimps small
group maybe 100 chimps uh troop they
have more genetic diversity within their
small population than 1 billion I'm
sorry then uh 8 billion or 7 billion
humans on Earth and this is uh this is
what came out this was in 2012. it's a
chimpanzee populations living in
relatively close proximity are
substantially more different genetically
than humans living in different on
different continents
okay and you can look it up there's been
a couple studies on that and essentially
they're saying you know these chimps uh
not only between troops but also within
troops they have more genetic diversity
than humans and uh you know these uh
animals they're um
they're very small populations we are 8
billion and we're all clones of each
other and so not everybody's aware of
that people have this notion that this
other fellow had that we create new
genetic diversity every day
and he says yeah sometimes we do have
crashes and that chops off
lots of people from the earth that could
have contributed to the gene pool
but that's not the only issue the issue
is like this other fellow said they were
he posted that uh note that uh
inbreeding leads to loss of genetic
diversity so the fact that we have
genetic diversity is over compensated by
far by inbreeding okay and so well all I
can tell you is what the facts are out
there if you believe there are other
facts well I can't help you anymore okay
and finally another file says a list of
very old species
uh he believes that again that
inbreeding does not conduce to loss of
genetic diversity or to the extinction
of a species eventually right and he
mentions all these species here that
live for hundreds 100 million years and
more okay so he goes through the list of
them and I'm just going to pull one out
of there okay because all this is
nonsense not a single one of these lived
you know 100 million years no species
lives a hundred millionaires so these
people just put these numbers there and
they never and analyze whether what what
this whether this data has any validity
okay these are just opinions of some
people who say Hey you know we saw this
animal in the record and we've seen him
today as well and so I guess this animal
has been around for 100 200 300 million
years
no such monster it never happened and
never will okay and let's pull out the
sealer comp there which is probably the
most uh famous case okay they're known
as the Lazarus species because they it's
like they are uh they came back to life
from the dead okay like Lazarus in the
Bibles that's where they got that name
and uh one guy uh did an analysis you
can look them up coelacons uh are not
living fossils okay and he goes through
there and he analyzes tells you look the
silicons of uh devonian and so on
millions of years ago are not the
coelacons of today
okay and so you just gotta read up on
coelacons and find out that they are not
the same animals I mean it's like saying
that Neanderthal is the same as us and
they're not believe me if a silicon uh
saw today you know these lungfish if
they would see one of these silicons uh
from uh 200 million years ago or
whatever they'd run the other way
they get scared of them they said no no
I'm not gonna mate with that one you
know they're they're so different
genetically that they would not be able
to make okay but people don't understand
that they say oh silicons are the
Silicon to the Silicon not true okay and
um and so here we show another example
and that's the bacteria specifically the
cyanobacteria
and uh there's a couple papers you see
them there uh there's a reference and
I'll just mention a couple of them uh
one fellow says how many species of
algae are there and he goes into talk to
about 30 000 species of algae and uh to
more than one million but specifically
says there's uh at least eight thousand
species of cyanobacteria with 4 700
remaining to be described and maybe just
touch the tip of the iceberg there if
anything now another paper uh so
cyanobacteria Evolution inside from the
fossil record you know we think that
bacteria have always been the same for
the last 300 400 500 million years and
these people are saying no uh the
cyanobacteria that we see around today
are not the same that there were like
300 400 million years ago and there you
just see uh the evolution of
cyanobacteria in the pre-cambian alone
you can see all the the species or the
different variations that evolved
okay so uh what's my point my point is
that
um
if if all these it just if bacteria
bacteria right if if they evolved and
they Diversified into so many species
variations or whatever you want to call
them
certainly any other animal
will it as well to think that a coelacon
or any other animals at this file
mention there remain the same for 200
million 300 million years is simply
irration
and I'm being Kinder with my words no uh
no species lasts a hundred million years
okay they evolve so much that if we were
to get uh one of the uh Lazarus species
one uh that's alive today and we were to
mate them or to attempt to mate them
with one 100 million years ago
they would not produce uh
Bible Offspring they would be so
different genetically that they would
not even recognize each other maybe they
don't even want to have sex reproductive
sex you know with each other
so no uh there are no Lazarus species no
species lasts a hundred million years
there's too much change going on in 100
million years even for bacteria let
alone for any other animal and here
we're talking about bacteria you know
they they're all over the land not to
mention viruses which are not living
entities okay but uh viruses also change
over time what do we have now coveted
instead of the flu maybe uh it's a
the mutation of the flu bug and now
we've got it as covid you know for those
who believe that
viruses are just molecules right yeah
all animals and uh all parasites like
viruses they uh change over time and so
if we went back into in time and looked
at viruses that existed maybe 300 400
million years ago we'd find that they're
quite a bit different than us because
otherwise it would mean that they did
not learn anything in their interactions
with the environment including you know
other species uh all everyone engages in
an arms race
so when someone develops an antidote the
other guy has to develop again you know
the way to survive and counteract that
antidote and that's called an arms race
and that's how species evolve
okay okay let's move on to the subject
matter today and what is that that's uh
something I call the
um
Universal movie
and let me show you why we had to create
this tool
it's a tool okay and let me show you why
here we have one fellow and he says the
following he says there's no such
physical presence as a cross-section of
time
I showed the other day that like for
states of matter versus phases of matter
you know I'm saying that we have to get
a cross-section of time such as the
state which is a static concept versus a
phase which is something in motion you
need two frames of the film to create a
phase you need only one for a state and
so these people have problems with that
because suddenly you know I'm stopping
the universe and they say well you can't
stop time
foreign
yeah no kidding you can't stop motion
we're making believe
and stop time you know like make believe
it's a thought experiment okay so he
says there's no such thing as
cross-section of time meaning you can't
stop time everything's always in motion
well you didn't have to tell us that we
all know this okay we all are aware that
you know motion is Perpetual okay in
both directions of time okay but all
physical presence is in uh motion always
fundamentally time is this constant
changing locations there's no pictures
uh frame no you know the single frame in
the Universal movie another fella says
the following says Bill all wrong about
definition of state of matter State
remembers the static concept right by
state of matter or state of aggregation
of molecules which I guess is not the
same thing aggregation is not the same
as a state we meet but he doesn't
understand that okay we can't we mean a
conventional classification of the
states that matter can assume depending
on on what the mechanical properties it
manifests
yeah but see the mechanical properties
it manifests is called motion that's
what you just talked about you that's
what you just defined you Define motion
so you're saying that a state is motion
that's what you said but of course he
doesn't do this kind of analysis uh
because they think it's word solid you
know they say no no I didn't come here
to do grammar I came here to do physics
and so they get tripped because they
don't do an analysis of the language and
all they do is copy paste you know they
look at the history of the word and they
put it in there and they say oh this is
what it's always meant this is what
people around the world think of it
we don't care here we analyze the word
and if it's irrational because it was
defined irrationally by our forefathers
people
hundreds of years ago then we corrected
we fixed that which is broken
and he said why is it important to
classify the state of matter
to destroy your religion
that's why we need to classify that's
why we need to
Define these terms we need to know what
we're talking about and when you talk
about state
unless you understand that state is a
static concept and that everyone in
mathematics treats it as a phase as a
dynamic concept they don't realize they
have a contradiction and all these
people they they just go out there and
say but look at what I found out there
in the dictionary in the encyclopedia
this is what the mathematicians say we
don't care about any of that we clean
our nose holes with all that we analyze
the the word if there's a problem with a
word we clarify what's wrong with it and
if there is something wrong with it then
we fix it okay
that's the way it works okay and then
finally we have another fellow uh and he
said the following he says uh it's all
word salad you know and says who the
hell cares about this word salad anyway
plasma will remain the fourth state of
matter
yeah all these ignoramuses you know they
they just want to continue using the
word plasma they want to use the word
ether they want to use the word uh wave
and when you say look let me tell you
what the word wave really stands for
it's a verb not a noun they say well
that's word sounded uh how do you come
here to do word salad or word analysis I
came here to do physics and they're
using all these words as nouns
and no not a single one of them is a
noun and for that I had to create this
tool called the uh Universal movie okay
so let's look at the universal movie
let's see what it's all about
here's a universal movie okay and it's
relatively simple if we look at a single
frame of the universal movie and we
think of the universal movie as simply
the distance between every object in the
universe at a cross section of time or
cross-section of motion it's really see
this far said uh earlier you said uh
there's no such thing as a cross-section
of time because time involves an
interval and you would think that enough
the time requires at least two frames of
the movie
of course that's true you need uh two
friends of the movie for motion and you
need two frames of the movie at least
for time okay so he says you can't have
a single frame
because that would not be time
and uh I don't know if that's what he
meant but that is correct if you have a
single frame you don't have either
motion or time what do you have and
that's what this uh
uh notion this tool called the universal
movie is for it says let's look at a
single frame of the universal movie we
see like if we stop the universe and in
there all you will see is objects that
means every atom in the universe every
electron every subelectron every micro
electron everything is stopped nothing
moves we have only static Concepts in
there we have distance which is
separation between objects we have
location and we have existence there is
no motion there is no such thing as time
for time and motion we need at least two
frames of the movie of The Universal
movie here we're talking about a single
frame okay
so what is it that we're actually doing
here well we're we're telling God you
know almighty God all-powerful God
all-knowing God we're telling him look
stop the universe because these people
have a runaway mind
and you know you you want to say look
before you move anything let's identify
the objects see all these people start
their theories their movies they start
them with a film strip they start them
in motion already he said no no I want
to see the first frame in in your movie
I I didn't get to see that
and they're already putting things in
there that are already in motion so they
already start the movie with a film
strip
so he told God please we pray and say
God please stop the universe because
these people are you know they have run
away minds and their their heads are in
motion
like this
quite a bit in motion okay and so God
goes in there and he stops the universe
at a single frame he chose in this case
frame number 32. he stops the clock okay
the uh Heavenly clock I guess and yeah
God moves and everything moves in heaven
but I guess you could say he's in a
different dimension right so we're going
to look at is a frame of our Universal
movie in that frame nothing moves okay
and for this we have to determine what
do we find in that frame if nothing
moves in the universe what is in there
what is in that universe that's what
we're going to try to try to figure out
and uh yeah for this
um we're going to have to look at uh
what I call the foundations of physics
okay because we need to identify the
main things that we need to do physics I
mean what kind of things do we want to
understand as far as a mechanism as far
as how the universe works well we
figured out all the visible stuff you
know you see I don't know a donkey
pulling a cart and someone asked well
how how did the cart move from A to B
this is very simple let me show you the
movie and the movie shows you know a
donkey tied to the cart pulling the card
and says see it was at a and now the
cart is at B and then uh the the owner
unhitched you know the uh donkey and
there's the cart
so that's how the cart move from maybe B
because everything is visible
that's why it's so easy because we can
see everything we can see the movie we
can watch it no problem
but now we see Bill Gates famous
experiment you know we see a pencil
falling
and you say why did that fall to the
floor
why did it fall to the scene because we
do it again let's do it again okay we
let go and there he goes
it falls downwards and never does it
fall outwards and you say well here I
didn't see the mechanism I don't know
the cause
why did it fall down
is something pushing the pencil from
above and something pulling on the
pencil from Below
and I don't think there's any other
possibility I mean it's either push or
pull those are the only two forces in
the universe okay that we can imagine
not like in Quantum where they have four
horses I mean four forces
okay so yeah they've invented four
forces in Quantum two of them are pool
and two of them are push you know so I
don't know what they really invented
there but there's only two forces push
and pull and the question is is
something pushing onto pencils or is
something pulling on it that's it
but we can't see it so we don't know if
something is pushing or something is
pulling and that's what we're trying to
figure out we're trying to figure out
the mechanism what is causing the pencil
to fall
and of course we're going to have to do
a lot of thinking here because there's
no way you can run an experiment and
determine
what invisible intangible object is
coming in contact with the skin of the
pencil to either push it or pull it
downwards that's the whole issue and
that's just one example the other one
would be magnetism how does the magnet
attract another same thing how does it
do it from a distance when you cannot
see whatever's pushing or pulling the
magnets together
so that's where you have to
fill in the word the blanks with a
thought experiment say well what if
you know what if uh we put something
there and find out how Mother Nature
could be doing this magic trick that we
can't figure out through see and touch
okay
okay so we go down to the foundations of
physics okay and these are the
foundations
first we need to know what science is
science is rational explanations it's
got two branches one is physics the
other one is philosophy those are two
branches and there ain't a third one
okay so everything falls under one of
those two physics studies rational or
not study but uh is in the process the
discipline right it is in irrationally
explaining what causes and mechanisms
that's what physics is about physics is
not about math physics is not about
running experiments or doing predictions
or anything like that doing observation
you know gawking and not understanding
physicist is about explaining what are
you explaining you're explaining causes
and mechanisms hopefully you do it
rationally otherwise you're doing
religion
okay and so we start with the golden
principle you can't do physic without an
object you need objects to do physics if
there were absolutely nothing in the
universe
completely empty space
what's happening what's going on what
are you observing what what experiment
would you run to begin with for those
who who believe in experiments you know
what are you seeing
now you need objects to just to have
mechanisms and that's what we're going
to try to explain how those mechanisms
work at the universal level as well as
at the micro level
and so those are the words that you need
to Define upfront because these are all
static Concepts okay there are still
Dynamic ones such as motion and uh you
also have Concepts I'm sorry words such
as concept you need to define those as
well but right now we're going to stick
to the static ones because remember
we're going to look at a single frame of
the universal movie okay and so here we
have it something we need to know what
something is what does the word
something mean
and it's the opposite of nothing
either you have something or you have
nothing there are antonyms hopefully one
is the opposite of the other and now we
can use them consistently as long as we
Define him property and we Define
something as that which has shape and
nothing as that which doesn't have shape
so we have good definitions we can use
them consistently for the purposes of
physics okay we call the something also
object and we call the nothing also
space
those are the words we're going to use
then we have distance separation between
two objects we call that separation
distance it's not a measurement it's
it's not involves numbers or units it's
simply qualitative separation okay
because Mother Nature father Universe
they don't they don't do measurements
all they say is this atom is over here
and that atom is over there and there's
separation between them
certain distance certain certain you
know Gap
uh location the set of distances you
want to know where any little atom any
electron in the universe is
you just take the static distances again
the separations to all other objects
that is the qualitative location of that
object with respect to all others okay
and you can take any subset of that and
do the same thing okay and then exist
well it's an object something that has
location
very simple so those are the main things
now you have a foundation with which to
build your theories of physics
what is physics causes and mechanisms
now you can explain causes and
mechanisms once you define these terms
that's the way it works now we have a
rational foundation on which to build
our theories of physics okay what are we
going to try and figure out we're going
to try to figure out stuff like
magnetism and gravity
which are intangible the mediators are
invisible and intangible therefore we
cannot run an experiment
make any predictions make any
observation none of the stuff that
mathematics uses we can't use any of
that in physics in physics we have to do
thought experiments and the way we do
the thought experiments is by
introducing objects in those uh
spaces right to find out how Mother
Nature could be doing attraction or
pushing or whatever it's doing
okay so that's what we do with this
here's um
here's uh the other uh same thing but in
uh you can say in pictorial form we have
an object there a cat it's got a
separation from another object called
the dog
and as contrast they have what is called
nothing that which has no shape okay I
put a shape there which is squarish or a
rectangular ish but uh that's because
you know I had to put a stop to my frame
only only because of that but nothing
has no shape therefore there is no
boundary to nothing
and what do we have between the cat and
the dog well we have distance it's known
also a separation Gap uh Chasm if you
want to call it whatever okay there's a
separation there
and then we move to the other static
group of static Concepts location which
is a set of distances between the cat
and maybe a tree and a chair or whatever
and as long as that cat has location we
say that the cat exists
okay uh the cat that I'm thinking of in
my brain that one doesn't exist because
it doesn't have location to begin with
okay so
uh the abstract cats that we have like
the one you drew on the paper the ink
and the pen have location but not the
cat Okay and then again all of this is
contoured or
um you could say it's uh
contrasted by nothing
okay so this is the notion this is uh
the foundation on which we are going to
start and yeah if we're going to isolate
a single frame of the universal movie
all we're going to see in that frame are
static Concepts objects
distance distances plural locations and
existence
that's all you have in a frame for the
purposes of physics okay and so here we
have an example okay we're going to go
through some example here to get the
hang of it because a lot of these people
with Wandering Minds they cannot keep up
with this unfortunately for them right
and here's a chair okay we can put it in
a single frame of the movie we call that
a solid okay
do we call it a solid because it's got a
lot of atoms or you know myriology no we
call it a solid because it's solid it's
uh not moving
no we call it a solid because it has
length width and height just like almost
any existing object and it's uh and we
can see it in a single frame okay it
doesn't move you don't have to for it to
to see an object such as a chair it does
not have to move you do not have to move
it now once you've identified the object
and now you identify it for the ET and
say look that's a chair you point to it
and call it chair now he learned your
language he knows what that object is in
your language it's called a chair and
now you can do whatever you want with it
you can move it around like you see
there at the bottom you can tell your
theory of what happened with a chair
right but you can point to the chair in
one frame of the film why because you're
just going to name it you're going to
give that thing that's in front of you a
name and you're going to categorize it
as a solid
okay here's another one okay uh this is
a liquid in this case milk
and again you can point to Milk okay and
say look uh that's that's a liquid it
falls under a category of liquid
and milk I can point to it with one
finger and call it milk it doesn't have
to be rolling like you see at the bottom
doesn't have to be dripping I can point
to milk a puddle in on the floor and
call it milk
okay it doesn't have to be moving in
order to for it to be milk because milk
is not defined as something that is
moving yet it forms part of the
categories called liquid
once you identify milk then you can put
it in your theory and say well it's
dripping and whatever you're going to do
with a milk in your theory so you can
have it moving later on but milk to
point to it and identify it you do not
have to you do not have to under any
circumstances have it rolling gripping
or moving in any way you can just point
and tell the ET milk and he learned the
word milk
does the word milk involve any motion
absolutely not okay it's a liquid no
liquid involves the definition of the
word liquid does not involve motion I
can point to any liquid in a static
frame it doesn't have to maneuver and
say that's a liquid
just like that
it doesn't have to be rolling dripping
moving nothing
here's another one uh known as gas it's
one type of gas it's called Vapor okay
and I can point to Vapor in a snapshot
and say look that's vapor
and I identified the word okay Vapor the
word Vapor does not include any motion
whatsoever I can point to that single
frame in that first frame frame number
one and say vapor and the uh ET
understands that that cloud of whatever
that is belongs to the category of
vapors I do not have to have it moving
like you see below I can later on have
it moving if I want for my theory but I
don't need to have it moving up front to
begin with I guess point and call it
Vapor okay and in fact uh here's a
picture of vapor uh in everyday life
someone took a picture and that's what
they looks like okay so uh yeah you can
have vapor in a single frame of the film
I point and say vapor and uh nobody's
gonna say Bill it's not moving yeah no
kidding because the word Vapor does not
include any provision for motion and
that's what these people do not
understand
they think uh let's talk physics no no
first we gotta talk language because you
don't understand language before we can
get the physics we need to understand
the language
okay
okay but uh let's look at some words
that are famous out there especially
among dissidents but also in the uh
establishment and here's the first one
uh it's the word ether okay
ether is always moving
so these people also say look uh I'm
gonna put ether in frame number one I'm
gonna point to it and call it ether
well you can't do that because ether is
always moving
ether is many particles okay you can't
point to it because uh you have to watch
it and right there I put it all in one
frame but you have to think of that as
something in motion therefore you're
already looking at a film which they put
in a single frame of the movie and
that's irrational that's surrealistic
okay and and yeah they say look uh light
is the waving of The Ether
what do you mean waving other ether The
Ether was already waving in uh or moving
in frame number one you put a film
inside a movie
inside a frame of the movie a single
frame of the movie that's where the
error is and they don't understand that
they don't understand that ether is
already in motion in fact uh it's many
particles and
um and that's called myriology and
myriology is irrational it's used in uh
what they call philosophy which ain't
philosophy either okay it's uh just
people who never identified what
philosophy is and they say oh I do
philosophy and ether is uh some kind of
myriology many many things in in one
frame you know that's unphysical in
physics we do not use such Concepts as
mariology meaning that a table is really
all the atoms that comprise an elephant
is all the atoms that comprise it no no
that's not an elephant elephant is what
I pointed to not all the atoms that make
up an elephant and that's the situation
with ether
now a lot of people say Bill yeah you
don't know what the ether is that's the
first thing they say they never tell me
what the ether is they tell me what The
Ether ain't and it ain't what I said
many particles uh-huh well uh they have
two choices only two they can either put
a picture of The Ether or anywhere on
the internet and say look this is The
Ether
and I do challenge you or warn you
really caution you don't look it up on
Google Images you'll get a hundred
different versions of what people have
for the notion of ether because they
never Define what the ether is no one
has any idea especially those who
propose ether they're having their tiny
little Minds you know what they think
the ether is so they never got in there
and really analyzed The Ether in any
detail no The Ether since the days of
the Greeks all the way to today has
always been many particles and that's
the notion they had they say The Ether
the many particles fills space it's a
substance that fills space they're all
vibrating and we call that vibration
light that was the notion that we had at
least since the days of um and uh
hook Robert Hook who came up with a
notion that light is some sort of wave
and we've had that for 400 years now and
so the ether is many particles and
they're always in motion if you don't
like it if you say that's not the ether
Bill no problem tell me what the ether
is by that you have to put a picture or
point to a picture somewhere on the
internet you know put a put a link and
say look at this link you'll find The
Ether what I say is The Ether okay good
but if you define ether and you say look
uh I looked it up on the Wikipedia or
some kind of Encyclopedia or the
dictionary or some mathematician out
there and he says this is what the ether
is if you can Define ether it's not a
physical object
objects we point to Concepts we Define
so you had better not Define the word
ether
okay because otherwise we can't use it
in physics as a physical object objects
are only those you can point to and they
have to have an image they have to have
shape and we don't care what it's made
out of so we don't need to see all the
little things that makes up the thing
that you call Ether it's got to be a
single piece
that's what that's the way we present
objects in physics you put to a table
you don't say well it's made of all
these parts got a leg and no no we treat
it as if it's made out of if it's made
out of a single piece you point to the
elephant it's like if the elephant is
made out of a single piece the word
elephant represents the whole thing and
not little pieces and say well this is
this is the tail of the elephant these
are the legs this is the trunk no no
that's an elephant what I pointed to the
whole thing as if it were a single piece
made of a single piece so mariology does
not participate in physics that's in
religion okay so don't tell me what it's
made out of and it's got a lot of
particles and so on The Ether had better
be something made of a single piece
that's got shape and I can point to if
you can't do it that way it's not a
physical object otherwise you have to
Define what an object is you got to
start there first
uh what word salad yeah let's do some
word salad okay
here's another uh famous word especially
used by dissidents electric Universe
they call this plasma
you have this uh these bees buzzing
around they call that plasma and as you
can see uh first frame is already moving
you say well hold it what do you mean
it's moving uh I wanted to see it
standing still
well the problem is you cannot see
plasma standing still
uh because if it's uh moving around and
every atom or most of those atoms are
ionized or some are recovering their
electrons some are losing their
electrons other are neutral they have
not yet either gained or lost an
electron and that whole soup is known as
plasma and it's something in motion you
cannot put Plasma in a single frame like
they like I did there and say that's uh
that's plasma no plasma requires two or
more uh frames of the universal movie so
you cannot put Plasma in a single frame
otherwise it's uh not only your ass it's
a surrealistic what you're doing is
putting uh film in a in a picture that's
what you've done there okay and we have
another famous word of Bessie of the
electric Universe it's called
electricity and they say it's the
movement of the electron beads from one
atom to the next and that's called
electricity
and they say I'm going to do this with
electricity I'm going to move
electricity this way and I'm going to
move it that way one file says you know
it's um uh you know like uh the
lightning has shape because he says I
took a picture of lightning and it's got
shape well you didn't take a picture of
lightning because if lightning is
electricity and electricity is the
motion of particles you cannot take a
picture of electricity electricity is
something in motion which is what you
see there and if you took a picture of
uh something that you think was that you
call electricity the picture does not
represent electricity that's only in
your head okay electricity is defined as
something in motion and so you cannot
put electricity in a single frame of the
movie of The Universal movie that's not
electricity whatever you took a picture
of whether it's plasma or electricity it
ain't plasma and it ain't electricity
you got that okay I hope so okay here's
another famous word this one's used
quite a bit by The Establishment it's
known as the word field they have this
thing which they say stretches all the
way to the edge of space-time wherever
that ends
and they always have it vibrating and
it's defined essentially as many values
in space so field is just a bunch of
values with units you know numbers with
units and then they have it moving they
say it's vibrating it's uh it's an
excited field so again they start with a
movie and they put that movie in a
single frame of the film and that's
irrational
and a couple more just to rub it in this
big bang and here the problem is that
they never started frame number one they
already have it exploding so they put a
little Dot and you say well how did that
dot get there I mean uh hopefully you
know there was a movement from frame
number one to frame number two
and I know they always start at the
explosion
or or that the dot was already there we
don't have the first frame where God
puts that a little dot in there called
The Singularity they say well we don't
know what happened frame number one well
how did he get there I mean if we're
going to talk about the origin of matter
the origin of the universe hopefully uh
you tell us how that little dot came
into being right was it God like the
religious folks say traditional
religious Folk and finally another one
the last one here we have a black hole
okay and the black hole also is defined
as a star that is collapsing upon itself
okay and they talk about escape velocity
okay that not even light cannot escape
and so they have all these Concepts
Dynamic Concepts of a black hole where
they're it's involved they all involve
motion whether it's the star collapsing
because of its gravitational uh
attraction to itself to its Center or
because uh they talk about the uh escape
velocity all these are Dynamic Concepts
that's how they start their presentation
and then they say well the black hole
does this and the black hole does that
now you can't do that you can't you
can't talk in those terms because you
haven't presented a static object you
have to stop the universe in order to be
able to talk about the objects you have
to stop the universal movie like we
showed earlier with God you know
stopping time
so that these people don't have these
runaway Minds that you know go around in
circles
okay so these are the reasons summary
here of why you cannot include any of
these words in physics as a noun
in ordinary speech you can call it a
noun not in physics physics only objects
can be nouns and so the ether it's a
these are definitions you'll find out
there the material that fills the region
of the universe beyond the terrestrial
sphere if it fills the universe and it's
many particles and it ain't an object we
don't care about mariology or about
motion plasma it's ionized gas so you
can't do anything with plasma because
plasma is not a thing plasma is a thing
in motion and you're going to put it in
motion you can't because it's already in
motion
electricity phenomena associated with
the presence and what motion of matter
electricity is already in motion
lightning which is electricity is
already in motion if you take a snapshot
of either plasma or electricity you
don't get either plasma or electricity
because plasma and electricity are
defined as moving things
okay so whatever you took a picture of
it ain't plasma and it ain't electricity
feel the quantity that has a value for
each point in space and time uh again
mariology they put all these values and
they say that's that's a field
now that ain't a field for the purpose
of the physics you can't use that as a
physical object and say the field moved
the wall
you can't do that not in physics it's
irrational and uh
either I'm going drunk and uh
shaving uh blurry or I lost uh
Focus here okay you have big bang a
theory that describes how the universe
expanded
so a big bang is already an expanding
Theory it's already in motion so you
can't talk about Big Bang as a thing
okay and again we're referring to the
singularity of the Big Bang because
that's where it all starts and again if
it's already in motion it's already
expanding if you start at frame number
two as the mathematicians always do they
never started frame number one they
don't know how that Singularity which is
a concept anyways got there
you can't use that Singularity and say
this is the Big Bang this is where it
all started in fact the word bang
suggests explosion explosion I think was
something in motion you know when you
say a hand grenade exploded you're now
talking about the hand grenade you're
talking about what it did explode and if
you bang the big well then uh you're
talking about motion and then finally
the black hole a region of space time
where gravity is strong gravity is
something in motion okay because you
talk about a region you're not talking
about a single point okay but even if
you were talking about a single point
what are you saying you're saying that's
not that's not the black hole the black
hole is what it's doing to everything
around it which is pulling it in okay
it's just saying look there's a lot of
gravity there for whatever reason and
um
uh again as he find us nothing including
light can escape it so again they talk
about escaping
you can't use any of those uh in the
Universal movie Universal movie every
frame in it only has location static
Concepts such as uh distance location
and existence that's those are the only
Concepts that you can use in a single
frame of the movie for the purposes of
physics and of course that eliminates
all these words that dissidents and
mainstream use alike like ether and
field and uh plasma and whatever
so that is the Roundup uh now you know
what the why that tool is so powerful
because it eliminates all these people
with runaway Minds that they cannot
conceptualize a single frame of the
movie nothing moving just every object
in the universe separated from all
others in a static picture static image
because that's the only way you're gonna
identify the objects that you're going
to use in your theory if you have
everything already moving like an ether
or field or electricity or plasma well
then you started you you started your
theory with a film strip not with a
single frame that's where you stand
okay
okay we had our um
famous
[Music]
um
science critic okay and this fellow made
a video 45 minute video uh uh
criticizing the scientific method the
rational scientific method and the
reason I analyze him is
um because in his 45 minutes he
essentially
represented what everybody out there
more or less believes in and or has been
brainwashed with high school and college
and so they just accept whatever the
mathematicians feed them they think
science is fine and dandy they don't see
any problem with anything and here we
are three thousand four thousand years
later and not a single person can tell
you how gravity Works how magnetism
Works how a magnet attracts another what
light is you know what is this thing
called light is it the vibration of the
ether as they said in the 19th century
uh they cannot explain a single
phenomenon out there they don't even
know what electricity is
or how the atom works because they don't
have a picture of the atom
you know uh and people say no no they've
taken pictures of the atom of the sun
with the atomic Force microscope
very simple
just draw for me and Adam and we'll know
if anyone knows on in the mathematical
establishment or those who follow them
if anybody can can draw a picture of an
atom I mean what is it a proton
surrounded by an electron
because the electron is known as a bead
it's known as a particle discrete
particle the proton is made out of three
particles quarks right but again it's
considered a single particle so we have
a single ball bowling ball 1800 times as
heavy as the electron and we have the
electron next to it that's the atom
is that is that what what they took a
picture of
show it to me show me the picture of a
proton
and an electron and tell me that that's
the atom that they took a picture with
uh Atomic Force microscope or any atom
you take the uh uranium atom if you want
no problem show me
uh just uh the nucleus and the electron
that's the one I want to see
have we seen electrons like little beads
around the uh
nucleus of the uranium atom is that what
we've seen
no of course not not a single person can
tell you what the atom looks like and in
fact they have these versions they call
it the cloud version the shell version
where you have like uh the way they draw
it at least they have this encapsulating
uh not membrane but what they have is an
encapsulating
um
energy level because they're going to
talk about math and they have this
little b jumping back and forth between
energy levels
so again they have the planetary model
to explain ionization Quantum jump
electricity
but then they deny that atoms say no
well that's by the way that's not our
atom
and so no we do not have a picture of
the atom from The Establishment
something that you can draw and say look
bill this is what the atom looks like I
mean that's how simple it is go look one
up show me what an atom is not the one
that they took a picture of because they
take them from far away bird's eye and
what you see is a ball
so we don't know what that is if if the
atom is a little electron rolling around
a nucleus you should not see a ball you
should see a little bead going around a
nucleus that's not what we see in the
pictures so what I don't want is a
photograph that they take or some kind
of image that they taken with a atomic
Force microscope or sound
what you need to show is a drawing show
me draw for me and Adam that's what I
need I need to know what you
conceptualize an atom as what are you
going to draw a nucleus surrounded by a
little uh electron bead
that's the issue okay so no nobody knows
what a uh an atom looks like in the
establishment or in the dissident world
like the electric universe and all these
other people
okay uh so this fellow
um he he did uh he essentially
represented what most people out there
think of physics the Notions they have
and it's all this mathematical gibberish
that they've been fed for the last 400
years and it's what they study in high
school and college and this is what they
repeat they just parrot it and that's it
so they never did an analysis of any of
this and it turns out this fellow now
made a new video someone pointed that
out to me and he made a video of um
uh analyzing the issue of predictions
and I won't get to that today
um
talking about prediction I'll address
that later on but uh this is what uh
what the new uh
uh video looks like more or less okay
and he says a confused man thinks
scientific predictions are useless he
was referring to me as the uh confused
man pseudoscientist number four okay
what caught my attention was uh that he
had his fingernails painted
and uh let me tell you something about
that uh it turns out that
um a few years ago I had a couple people
here three three boys three uh 20 year
olds and
um I had heard that men shaved their
legs
and I I think that maybe it was one guy
who did that but I didn't think it was
so popular that it was a fad
and so I told these three guys if they
could you know pull up their pants so
that I could see their Shins
and they didn't know why but they all
complied and they all pulled up their
pants and showed me their Shins
all three of them have had their sins
shaved off
and I thought that was kind of weird
but this guy beat them all because I
mean he he painted his uh fingernails
okay so that was uh
kind of strange and um yeah I guess so
we do live in strange times it just
confirms for me that yeah we are the
last humans on earth when we start doing
things like this these are not just fads
there's a little more involved than just
a fad here okay that's the way I look at
it at least anyway we start doing things
like that it's because uh
uh we live in strange times
okay so what did uh Mr fingernail do uh
he uh did the following he uh talked
about
um truth okay and so we'll hear it from
the horse's mouth this was the issue and
let me put this on let me get this
rolling so that you can see what the
issue is about here it goes
the questions and issues to be addressed
today include
and what is true today
be shown to be false tomorrow
if so
was yesterday's truth a truth to begin
with
and is truth also known as knowledge a
synonym of belief
the science of today could be shown to
be false tomorrow but the only way that
we could find out if science is false is
by obtaining more knowledge if someone
shows that your knowledge is wrong then
that will no longer be a Justified true
belief although that is quite a
philosophical Rabbit Hole to dive down
which involves talking about what
exactly is truth and this is kind of the
point that I'm getting at about truth
what one person considers to be true may
be entirely different to what another
person considers to be true
okay so um this appears to go in in
circles
uh what does fingernail say he says the
following he says as I understand it at
least scientists is the same thing as
truth truth is knowledge knowledge is
belief therefore science is belief is
that what science is all about belief
um unless you can correct that that
seems to be his train of thought and
I've been looking at you know several of
his video or analyzing different aspects
of his video and so yeah he believes
that science has something to do with
true truth with now there's knowledge we
believe and so we end up with science
equal to believe so he goes around in
circles to say the same thing I told him
in my video I said yeah that all these
people think that
uh science is just belief convincing
people persuading them to believe your
theory and and if you persuade 50 plus
one your theory becomes a fact or
knowledge or whatever they call it but
then he says oh uh what we knew for a
fact yesterday what was truth yesterday
today we can uh discard and say well it
wasn't the truth
so was it the truth yesterday if today
you showed it to be false or a lie or
just a unwarranted belief
so so we got a contradiction because
these people go around in circles and
they don't realize it they say look
science is about seeking the truth truth
is about knowledge
knowledge is belief science is belief
but no uh it's about uh the truth about
seeking the truth
if you can prove your knowledge wrong
yesterday that means it wasn't knowledge
it wasn't true
it was irrational it was a lie it was a
falsehood you can't say that what was
true yesterday is false today truth is
eternal
always
and if you discover that it's no longer
the truth
you proved it like they say math then
yesterday true yesterday's truth was not
truth
all it does is negate that they had the
truth in the past you know in the old
days God was truth
they had proved it everybody believed it
and a lot of people today are
questioning now and there's a lot of
atheists and so on they say no God does
not exist God is Not Truth
uh I know God does not exist
and so uh so what does that do to the
truth and knowledge we had
500 600 you know a thousand years ago
it's just that that wasn't the truth it
wasn't knowledge that was a lie
so in retrospect it was not knowledge it
was just a belief and that's what truth
and knowledge are just beliefs what is
true to you like this fellow says is a
lie to your neighbor or a falsehood or
he doesn't believe it
and so your truth is not his truth
and they don't understand that they keep
talking about knowledge and Truth in in
the context of science when knowledge
and Truth as this guy says it's just
belief it's just everybody's opinion
is science about opinion
science about belief I thought that was
religion
okay and yeah here's uh
one phone he says I think the following
he says philosophy is search for truth
well so we don't know if uh physics is
the search for truth science it's a
search for truth or philosophy is the
search of Truth and we'll never find out
until until you define philosophy as
long as we don't have a definition for
philosophy or we have 10 different
definitions or none at all like in the
case of the Stanford encyclopedia what a
philosophy no definition whatsoever then
we don't know what philosophy is and you
cannot say philosophy is the search for
truth okay because like this guy would
say maybe science is the search for
truth
and uh here's the breakdown
um if what is true today can be false
tomorrow then was it true to begin with
that's the only question you really have
to answer
and when one believed what one believed
to be true can be shown to be a lie if
and only if you convince the believer
if you cannot convince the believer he
continues to believe in his truth which
happens to be different in your truth
again truth is just an opinion okay so
if truth is just a belief at least among
humans now Mother Nature that's
different
Mother Nature father Universe they know
the truth
what do I mean by that I mean that you
know they have in their file cabinet
somewhere in the past what actually
happened and how it happened
you know if we could tune into Mother
Nature's brain and read it or go to her
file cabinet and find the actual you
know pictures and films of what actually
happened then we would be in touch with
the truth that's the truth that's
exactly what happened
but you know uh we can only speculate
now I'll give you an example you know
someone who was witnessing a murder
yeah he says Joey killed Susie
okay he was there he saw it he says I
know the truth
now he comes to you and he said Joey
killed Susie
well you say well but that's your
opinion no no I was there I saw it with
my own eyes
I don't believe you
so again uh maybe the person who
witnessed it uh shares the knowledge
that Mother Nature has but uh all other
people need to be convinced persuaded
that that's the truth meaning they're
gonna have to believe
in your version of the truth
the only way they can really be
absolutely sure and share Mother
Nature's truth is by going to her filed
cabinet that's why truth and knowledge
have nothing at all to do with science
truth and knowledge belong exclusively
within religion because they uh they
rely on there are synonyms of belief
that's all they are among humans
okay
okay uh we had some questions out there
people uh ask questions or uh made some
comments one fellow sends me a video or
sent me to a video and the fellow shows
this and he goes wow look at all this
stuff and there's a lot of videos like
that the wow videos where someone does
something with magnets especially and
shows something fancy and people go oh
look at that and here's this guy okay
you know he shows us all these little
things moving on the floor
okay
and the fellow says wow look at all this
stuff it moves like all by itself that's
so neat
you know the question here is when you
go to that video you don't find that the
guy explains the mechanism how this
happened how this was done
okay all these shows that things are
moving on some kind of platform there
okay but he doesn't explain how it's
done and he just says look I've
discovered these effects
I've discovered that if I do this this
and that I get all these motions you
know on on this board or on this metal
platform or whatever
so so people get wowed by technology and
they they even say look this could be
used for this this and that
and they never tell you how it's done
which is the scientific part
and so they skip the science they call
themselves scientists because they did
something that Wows the audience like
you know Faraday used to wow people uh
in those days in his days by doing some
experiments saying look what I found I
found that if you do this you know a
magnet attracts another
okay Fahrenheit smarty pants
how does the magnet attract another one
oh I don't know but isn't this you know
uh so fancy isn't that a neat trick
so you know all these people just play
around with a lot of Technology but they
don't know how it happens especially the
invisible intangible stuff the
mechanisms they don't they can't they
cannot explain it because the only way
you're going to explain it is by
representing
the mediators the invisible intangible
mediators with some kind of object you
have to make it visible
tangible if you want you know so that
someone can see how the mechanism works
again if someone goes like this and the
donkey comes closer to him
and you don't see the what's what's in
his hands what's pulling on the donkey
you say oh he did it by Magic how did he
do that
but if you make the Rope visible and you
say he's pulling on a rogue then it's a
kid stub you say Well that's that
doesn't require any brains to explain
that it's only because we cannot see the
Rope and the guy's just going like that
that people say wow look at that how did
he do that
and that's what Mother Nature that's how
Mother Nature fools us because he goes
in there and she does all these tricks
with intangible invisible mediators and
that's why we say wow look at that a
pencil falls to the floor doesn't fall
to the ceiling
a magnet attracts another from a
distance how does it do it
well unless you put a mediator there
you're never going to figure it out and
you certainly won't find out doing an
experiment you know what do you got to
do go to the lab and show a billion
times that a magnet attracts another
what have you learned you need to figure
out the mechanism and for that you need
objects you need to put a mediator
physical meteor in there otherwise
you're doing black magic and mother
nature does not do black magic
Palo says here he says
um do you think the Earth is
electrically connected to the Sun
oh man that's a can of worms the first
one there you see uh you know the uh
folks in the electric Universe they have
Zeus you know throwing his
his
um
uh what is it uh his rays and somehow
you know uh the sun pulls on the earth
even though electricity is
you know officially right in the uh
establishment and even the dissonance
like electric Universe they have all
these beads going from Adam to Adam
so in in the upper one there you see
them going in One Direction the bottom
one is you the bottom couple you see
them going in the other direction
great so how does that connect the Earth
to the Moon
I mean you know every
uh ball that you see in there is
discrete so they're not connected even
if that were the case even even if we
could put atoms in there but the other
issue is that you know
what you have between the Earth and the
uh Sun aside from magnetic field is the
um solar wind solar wind does not have
all those atoms that you would need to
create electricity
I mean if you're going to put
electricity between the Earth and the
Sun like the electric Universe does and
says that uh electricity is really
gravity is really electricity well then
you would need to put gazillions of
atoms between the Earth and the Sun
and at that point you couldn't even keep
them uh you know invisible you would
have some object stretching from the
earth of the Sun as a single stick at
least not to mention all the other
planets and you would have all these
sticks running around
so uh they're not connected for sure and
a lot less with electricity because
electricity as you see there is the
motion of the electrons from atom to
atom and we don't have gazillions of
atoms between the Earth and the Sun
okay don't tell me about charge don't
talk to me about uh the values and
numbers we don't care about that we're
talking about physics here and if you're
going to do electricity and explain the
mechanism of why the Earth doesn't leave
the solar system and you're going to say
that it's electricity that binds one to
the other what you have is the flow of
beads and you would have to have good
zillions of atoms we would be able to
see the object
and it would be a single block of
whatever that unites the uh Earth to the
Sun
so we have to destroy that notion for
this we have to look also at under our
Theory what what is uh electricity under
the Rope model so let's look at that
here we have
um uh start out with iron we're going to
build a wire so that you understand the
mechanism this is iron more or less what
iron looks like this is the outer shell
we're going to have all these atoms
connected and we're going to build a
wire so that's a wire okay let's look at
it again one more time we have the iron
atom okay
these are the orbitals really they're
membranes physical membranes we're going
to bind them we're going to have them
um merge these shells and we're going to
build our wire that's a wire okay do we
have that
and what we're going to do is we're
going to spin the wire we're going to
spin all these molecules here it is the
spinning of these molecules let me get
rid of this one here
okay so uh same thing at the top but at
the bottom you're going to see that the
um wire spins
okay you see how it's spinning so it's
totally in situ in place okay it's just
rolling around itself
they're all all the atoms are merged
they form the wire and the wire inside
it the molecules are spinning that's
what I'm showing there okay so it's the
molecules that are spinning uh domains
regions okay
okay so that's where we start so that
you get an idea and when they're
spinning they're going to swing the
threads around themselves that's going
to be the magnetic field which is going
to be go perpendicular to the motion of
electricity remember electricity you can
be in what we sense from one pole to the
other and the threads are going to go
around that's going to form the magnetic
field but we're not concerned about the
magnetic field we're just concerned
right now about
um
just the the
um what is it the um electricity okay
okay so here we have
um
a second here here we have the Earth
okay
and uh here we would have all these
atoms rolling because that's what uh
circuit would be just a long line of
merge shells and we just made it simple
here we're just using hydrogen atoms
here to make it just to simplify and if
the Sun is connected to the Earth we
would have still just like in I
explained a minute ago we would have all
kinds of atoms
you know between the Earth and the Sun
and obviously that's not the case uh the
um the the the vacuum level of the solar
wind is a 10 to the minus 12 10 to the
minus 13
um uh tour which is almost no atoms
whatsoever okay and so here you see a
bunch of atoms and if uh we're talking
about you know connection between the
Earth and the Sun we would have
gazillions of atoms here I just show one
line okay that's what it would be under
the uh rope model and of course that's
not the case okay so um
so the first thing we need to do is uh
kind of you know uh delete that and say
look that's that's not the case so here
it is that's that's not the case that
we're connected to the sun okay okay so
um what what is uh then
um
you know how are we connected to the Sun
well the way we're connected to the sun
is through uh ropes not through atoms
and uh that means that every atom in the
sun is connected to every atom of the
earth and the uh Sun swings the Earth
around like
a ball being swung at the end of a
string you know like this that's how the
the uh Sun uh towards the Earth around
because every atom
that comprises the Earth is connected
physically connected to every atom of
the Sun
okay and there are no atoms in between
very few atoms there are some atoms but
very few essentially it's Adam over here
at them over there and they're connected
by these ropes which are invisible and
intangible hopefully because uh I don't
think anybody has been able to touch
light you know the mediator of light or
the mediator of gravity so hopefully
they're invisible and intangible and
every atom on Earth is connected to the
every atom in the sun the sun just
Twirls the Earth around that's that's
why that's how we're connected not
through electricity electricity would be
the flow of beads in the case of quantum
which Quantum doesn't uh
you know uh theorize that neither does
my theory saying that you know all atoms
are interconnected that's what and they
all Spin and situ that's electricity
that's not what's happening either what
is happening is the Earth is swung
around by gazillions of threads
invisible intangible hopefully because
light and gravity are the mediator are
invisible and intangible so you have to
reproduce Mother Nature's world not the
one you want okay it's got to be
invisible intangible objects
okay here's another phone he says the
ether is something
yeah a bunch of uh particles
uh ether means all ropes that are not
atoms uh-huh and are not threads under
my theory he would say okay he's trying
to fit my theory into the word ether
that's what he's trying to do and
mathematicians insist that
um emptiness is full that nothing is
something meaningless claim okay he's
right there if instead we consider your
hypothesis that everything is connected
by single objects called ropes one can
imagine how all space is full
and no these people what they're trying
to do they're they're trying to salvage
uh The Ether at under any cost you know
uh they don't care what what lies behind
they're trying to change the notion of
the word ether that's what they're
trying to do either is a bunch of
particles and not a bunch of ropes
nobody ever said that ethers a bunch of
ropes they'll use the word don't
introduce the word ether into my theory
has nothing to do with it ether is
something else ether remains a bunch of
particles don't point now and say no eat
there's a bunch of ropes nobody says
that nobody ever said that we don't need
the word ether at all we just say ropes
and another problem with the uh that
notion that he just mentioned is that if
if that's true that uh the ropes fill
space every bit of space meaning there
is no such thing as space because the
ropes
um
fill everything
then what distinguishes what
distinguishes one rope from another rope
how are they isolated if there is not
some separation meaning space
so we cannot have Rogues fill space
completely
any more than you can have particles
fill space completely because then how
do you distinguish one particle from
another particle
the only way you can do that is there is
a separation between particles that
separation is known as space therefore
all particles cannot fill all of space
there's got to be space and particles
and that under that situation in which
case you cannot say that the ether is
the same thing as space that's one issue
and the other one you would have to
explain whether it's infinite or not and
good luck with that one because if it's
infinite you're saying that there's uh
all these balls extending all the way to
the kingdom come
you know and all you said is that they
keep growing as I count them so yeah The
Ether has to die period either is what
the quantum uses and what the relativity
uses space time is ether and a false
vacuum or whatever they want to call it
these days is The Ether nothing has
changed in 3000 years since the days of
the Greek The Ether is Alive and Well in
quantum mechanics and general relativity
they just gave it new names as uh what
was it Laughlin Nobel Prize Laughlin
said says uh we don't call it the ether
because it's taboo
okay and final issue here uh follow a
little sad says I was wondering if there
is a physical reason that magnetism does
the right hand rule that would seem to
indicate that the magnetic threads
always sweep in the same direction so
there must be a mechanism
why
and the answer is that it's it's all the
direction which you look at it you know
there you see the uh electrons merge the
electron shells remember they are
membranes they merge and they form these
long what I call serpentines okay and
that's electricity electricity is not a
little bead that goes from atom to atom
as it is in the electric universe or
quantum mechanics no electricity is the
spinning in-situ of merged electron
shells we call them serpentines okay and
they spin in situ when they spin as you
see on the bottom they sweep
the threads around themselves okay and
that's going to be the magnetic field
which is at 90 degrees to the direction
of what they call current flow there is
no current flow current is a drill bit
truly in place that swinging threads
around perpendicular to the motion of
the drill
okay so that's more or less how you got
to look at this and so from One
Direction it's counterclockwise from the
other it's clockwise
so that's the famous right hand rule it
just depends on from where you're
looking at it the threads apparently
move into counterclockwise Direction so
if electricity goes into your eyes which
is the counterclockwise according to one
version because there's two versions
there's the other version as well but if
if you take counterclockwise electricity
as you as it's considered today going
into your eyes the threads will be at 90
degrees moving also in the
counterclockwise Direction 90 degrees to
the so-called current flow and that is
the right hand rule right so I hope uh
physics replaces this nonsense about you
know uh mathematics and uh and how they
how they um
describe it in mathematics
okay with that I'll see you next week
folks we'll see you next Sunday